hey guys it is right over 30th of
January today which means I've got five
of this week's best game these stories
to get you all caught up going through
Microsoft to reveal their earnings for
the final quarter of last year so for
the first time in a while we get a look
at Xbox one sales numbers or rather
another look at their shipping numbers
the company shipped over 6.6 million
Xbox ones to retailers in the fourth
quarter of 2014
down from 7.4 million in the same period
in 2013 Microsoft said the Xbox one
outsold the ps4 during November and
December last year but revenues is a
total Xbox platform fell 20% due to what
Marcus called customer preference for
new generation of consoles the company
got a nice boost from first party games
like minecraft and halo the Master Chief
collection and posted an overall figure
of twenty six point five billion dollars
worth of revenue reporter the
PlayStation Vita might be taking a step
back with the elimination off some of
its apps the Vita will be dropping its
YouTube and Maps applications over the
coming months while YouTube videos can
still be watched through the browser the
app is no longer available on the
PlayStation Store all features of the
Maps application and some features of
the PS Vita near app will be disabled
through a software update in March
give yourself to crashing down and
fortune like copies of their games even
when those copies have been purchased
specifically users who bought slightly
discounted keys for Givi games through
reseller sites such as G to play and
kinguin may have found that their games
have been deactivated affected games
include Far Cry 4 and Assassin's Creed
unity Ubisoft are advising that
customers contacts the grain market
seller they bought the game off to
obtain a refund that gamers are feeling
generally burned that they're
legitimately purchased games are being
deactivated as if they were pirated and
the Eevee went after them instead of the
sellers and now for some free stuff if
you've got yourself a PlayStation Plus
or xbox live subscription if the games
you can get for free this February these
Sony fans on February 3 you can get
transistor and a puppy in for ps4 user
for and thief for ps3 and rogue legacy
and tick and clinic for your beta over
in the realm of Microsoft on Xbox one
you can get quirky platformer fighter
party game I dub for free or a month on
Xbox 360 between February 1 and 15 you
can get brothers a tale of two sons
which was my favorite game from 2013 and
from February 16 to 28 you can pick up
Sniper Elite v2 finally CD Projekt RED
have dropped the resolution details for
the witcher 3 on consoles the urban
world RPG is skipping last gen but us
the current gen it will be running at
1080p and 30 frames per second on ps4
while on Xbox one it'll be a slightly
lower 900p at 30fps CD Projekt RED have
two phones these numbers are correct let
me know down in the comment
new things new beefs up - deactivating
the game keys from the grain market
fellows worth a good away the hand of
the situation or not as for what's on
site this week check out my jist episode
on 2015 remix that are actually worth
your time Skyrim mods get sneaky and in
two minutes proposes a great Battlestar
Galactica game as always let me know
what you can about this week we sorta
have yourself a lovely weekend and I'll
catch you again on Monday